when we talk about personality one of
the things that they might be interested
in is how do I become less anxious or
more outgoing or more socially confident
in the big five trait theory is trait
extroversion basically and it's a
continuums we will score somewhere on
extraversion the talking about
introverts and extroverts is kind of not
so scientific in a way because you know
where is the cutoff point is
extroversion not to do with like valence
to positive experience or something like
that that's right that's an important
difference from how we use the term in
kind of colloquially one key thing about
extroverts is that they're very much
driven to achieve reward and positive
emotion so they seek out positive
emotion it's probably one of the reasons
why they are more socially active if
you're a high score on extraversion tend
to be more optimistic more active
extroverts are actually more like
exploratory in a way introverts are less
responsive to positive reward they're
less seeking stimulation they're chill
Seekers you know rather than Thrill
Seekers